[music]
n
me me book
[music]
maybe
n me
5 minutes
ha
hey
Then it's me
t you nn
[music] nn
open
[music]
nn yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I bought the first pair of shoes in Tokyo one day I went out of my way to buy them like that
, but in the end they were still brand new.
My dream
is that kids these days are going to quit right away.
I was a poor child, and after
quitting, I learned about the harshness of the world
.
It
's my fault, isn't it?
[Music]
Hello,
I feel
like I'm going to buy a ticket,
and it overlaps with my trip, so
it's okay.
I've already told them about the situation, so even if I keep
it a secret, it'll spread quickly
.
[music] I
can see
you,
I understand your troubles.
You're the honor student type You can't refuse even if you don't like it Your skin is
glossy and you're in your late teens
Traveling alone from Tokyo
Um,
why is there such a great fortune teller in such a
small shop?
Oh, it's time,
I'll
take a serious look once in a while 4 a Here's the
date of birth change There's
nothing good about it lately It
's time to get lost Aim for the constellation Sagittarius, which
will appear when the sun goes down A
good encounter should be waiting for you,
good
Okinawa  It's a fate that
we met here.
]
meme
feeling
[music]
booming
[music] um [music]
uat 4
[music] um
[music]
God, Tsunekichi
smell it
okay
[Music]
Grandma, I'm late today
.
After all, the
number of days I attended wasn't enough,
I guess I worked too much.
I
'm not only interested in fish, but I'm also a little bit more interested in humans
.  It's more interesting
, so I'm sure I put it a lot, but that
female teacher's lifespan is about a year, and sometimes she becomes a woman who jumps out of the aquarium.It
's really hard to raise.
Please start the story
I know it's not over
Please, Impa is back Are you on a trip
?  Music]
me
[music]
pos I'm so tired,
Mr. Pooh
Eh, line shift The
sea is still too tight for my waist,
so I'm going to rest Posey seems to be busy too.
I wrote to Messi when I took a big
breath.The customers are always
coming in.
Kirei-
kun,
if you're hiding in a corner like this, everyone wo
n't notice you.It's the
same.
But I'm actually a hard worker than anyone else He's a hard worker
who eats rocks and moss on the glass to keep the aquarium clean
I've been working hard too
[music
]  What the hell
[music]
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
4 days
[Music] It's not that simple
[Music]
Yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
Maybe
I could see it right now
Aquarium is a strange place, isn't it?
I can only see
it, but sometimes
there are times when I can see more mysterious things.
If it's your first time entering,
I'll show you around But welcome is true I pray I'm the director
of this place On the
sandy beach over the cape, I draw a precious place with my fingers The
ripples
come and
go I'm going to faint while still wet
toki ni
ah ah ah
[music]
ni
ah ah ah
[music]
me
Kama is a natural cave in Okinawa
.
There were a lot of sad things during the war
, but it seems that long ago
it was said to be a place that connected this world and the other world
.
I've been told that it's more like a grandma's living room in the countryside
With a touch pool where
you can interact I'm taking a break for a while.